Whiplash now first of all I read this
script it is you know up there with you
know A Few Good Men Juno it's up there
with the most brilliant things I've I've
ever read so I want to do it and this is
we're having a meeting to to spend a
three-day weekend making a short film
for which everybody's gonna get paid 173
dollars but it none of that matters
because it's sheer Brilliance you know
and I and I want to be a part of it we
sit down one of the first things he says
is I want to take the onus off of you as
far as the technical aspects of this
character and I looked at him I'm sure a
little bit oddly and I said dude I I
went to music school I thought I was
going to be a composer and conductor he
wrote it with miles in mind not knowing
that Miles had been playing drums in
cheesy rock bands You Know ever since he
was in eighth grade so I mean the
combination of a lifetime of of
preparedness that brought the three of
us together on that project